[Music]
Look at this rectangular ob kept on the
table are there any forces acting On it
Yes There is a gravitational Force
pulling it Down and an equal and
opposite normal Force pushing it up As
the forces are balanced the net Force is
Zero and hence  the ob will continue to
be at rest unless Another external Force
acts On it Now if We Push the ob towards
the right What happens the ob moves
towards the right Correct Yes That's
because We applied a Force toward the
right and the forces w unbalanced did
you  notice how we draw the Action of
forces Yes We use arrows and that should
Tell Us an important thing about Force
it is a Vector quantity it Has magnitude
and Dire We can Say That We applied a
Force of 5 New towards the right Don't
worry  about the unit of Force we will
understand it later but for Now Just
understand that Force is a Vector
quantity if We would have Said that We
applied a Force of 5 newt to the object
you wouldn't know how the Force is
applied and in which  Direction the ob
would move it could have been in any
Direction but the fact that We Said
Right means That it will be in this
Direction Which are the forces acted on
the ob When it mov to the right there
was this Force Which We applied then
Were  forces of Air resistance and
friction towards the left then Why did
the ob Still moov towards The Right the
upward and downward forces cancel each
other so the question of the ob Moving
upwards or downwards will not arise so i
mov to the right because the Force of  5
newt is more than the Sum of these two
forces Which w acting towards the left
also notice the size of the arrows if
the magnitude is more the size is also
larger this diagram you see Here is
called a free body diagram Looking At it
will Give  Us an overall İdea if the
forces are balanced or not and that in
Turn will also Give Us an İdea about the
direction in which the ob is going to
move the best Way to understand Force is
by understanding free body diagrams in
The Next lesson we will  Look at a few
interesting examples based on this
[Music]
Concept
i